le canada ou la fête ses 50 ans depuis
sa création en 1965 l'organisme de
mobilité a permis à des milliers de
réunionnais de sauter la mer désormais
la mobilité s'inscrit dans un parcours
d'excellence une préparation départ pour
permettre d'envoyer les plus motivés
tenter leur chance et trouver du travail
dans l'hexagone en 1983 conseil prendre
une décision importante c'est de
faciliter la mobilité pour l'emploi en
métropole mais à ce moment là le
collectif décide de confier la mise en
place d'un service entre la réunion et
la métropole
pour favoriser cette fois non plus comme
cela mais aussi des départs dès 50 ans
est un âge avancé un bilan était
nécessaire ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que
l'institution a évolué tant dans ces
métiers que dans ces dispositifs que
dans sa manière de de travail et nous
sommes aujourd'hui sur des dispositifs
novateurs avec alternance
nous sommes maintenant sur l'ouverture à
l'international nous sommes sur plus de
professionnalisme au niveau des actions
de préparation en mobilité sur un
accompagnement qui est beaucoup plus
pointues en métropole donc une vieille
dame qui se porte bien question d'un
costaud les jours depuis 2007 plusieurs
conventions de partenariat ont été
signées avec des organismes tels que la
mission locale le pôle emploi le rsm a
ou encore la chambre des métiers
lucknow développe différents dispositifs
pour accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi
parmi ces dispositifs le contrat
d'apprentissage et le contrat
d'alternance rencontre un vif succès le
groupe casino disney ou encore monoprix
permettent à des jeunes de se former
tout en préparant son diplôme sur ce
partenariat
ce qui ce qui frappe c'est dans un
premier temps tout ce qui concerne la
présélection des candidats puisque
aujourd'hui
en fait non recrutés essentiellement sur
de l'alternance et donc quand on vient
recruter
ici les candidats savent déjà pour
quelle entreprise ça déjà sur quel
métier et du coup on a des taux en fait
d'un gauche qui sont très satisfaisants
aujourd'hui puisqu'on est aux alentours
de 60 70 % une centaine d'entreprises
partenaires permettent aujourd'hui à
deux jeunes réunionnais de signer un cdd
ou encore un cdi cédric a eu un parcours
exemplaire son courage à payer
aujourd'hui il a décroché un cdi sa mère
témoigne
il a eu son bac pro qui t'a vu son bac
trop et puis pas de place ici en bts
pour lui parce que avec 13 95 moyenne
la mention assez bien mais pas mention
bien et pour avoir une mention pour être
au lycée il faut avoir en bts les
mentions bien et donc panique à bord
on ne sait pas on est au mois de juillet
on sait pas comment les choses vont
quand se déroulent et donc je me
retournais d'une arme et là ils ont
juste été je trouve pas de mots pour ça
puisque l'accompagnement effectivement
il ya eu l'accompagnement financière
c'est une bonne chose il ya
l'accompagnement une fois qu'on arrive
là-bas sur site
jérôme peut aussi se féliciter de sa
progression professionnelle cet
autodidacte a trouvé dans la mobilité la
force de réussir ses relations ses
opérations aux sénateurs et pêcheurs et
avec une équipe d'aujourd'hui 400
personnes sont en responsabilité incombe
schématise un petit peu de sable un
directeur général et moi avec toute une
équipe
en complément et sachant que moi
commence en tant qu agent d'exploitation
c'est-à-dire vraiment en bas de
l'échelle et celles à france 2 d'être
présent de rien refuser
et toujours de proposer sa son service
que petit à petit d'entre eux tu nous a
fait confiance et son rival en 2014 ce
sont 2000 37 réunionnais qui ont pris la
destination de la france métropolitaine
25% ont fait l'objet d'un contrat par
alternance
désormais l'objectif fixé de 5000 départ
pour permettre au plus grand nombre de
profiter de la mobilité une opportunité
professionnelle avec au bout l'espoir
pour ceux qui en rêvent de revenir un
jour travailler au pays